2 yvelinoise se lancent à l'aventuré
juliette 48 ans originaire de versailles
axel 39 ans de verneuil-sur-seine vont
participer au premier rallye 100%
électrique et 100% féminin le dépeint
sera donné le 9 mai prochain depuis
versailles
un projet inédit qui a séduit les
participantes là c'était vraiment
l'occasion d'avoir un rallye en rupture
un rallye complètement différent où
l'objectif c'est pas un objectif de
vitesse mais c'est vraiment il ya
vraiment une notion d'environnement et
de respect de l'environnement
puisqu'en fait il va falloir relier un
point à point b en imitant l'énergie
consommée au maximum pour réussir à
parcourir l'ensemble des 800 km de cette
course d'orientation les deux
aventurières comptent sur leur
complémentarité
elle travaille ensemble chez
l'entreprise yvelinoise vd com
spécialisé dans l'immobilité autonome
c'est une collègue que j'apprécie
beaucoup
on est très complémentaires moi je suis
plutôt la communicante
elle s'est plutôt l'ingénieur fans de
mecha et on se dit qu'à nous deux on
allait faire une très belle équipe on
est complémentaires niveau professionnel
mais aussi au niveau personnel
on a des qualités complémentaires axel
elle est très organisée sont bonnes
gestionnaires
moi je suis plutôt la créative
enthousiaste donc je pense qu'on va bien
s'entendre
cette amitié sera soumise à rude épreuve
pendant ces six jours de compétitions le
trajet se fera uniquement avec une carte
et une boussole sans téléphone ni gps
pendant que les véhicules se
rechargeront les équipages devront
poursuivre leur route à pied dans les
montagnes sur 10 kilomètres chaque jour
un programme qui n'effraie pas les
yvelinoises on espère être dans les
trois meilleurs équipages a bien sûr
puisque ce sont les trois premiers qui
seront récompensés on est douze
équipages et bien sûr va on espère
trouver des balises le plus rapidement
possible puisque l'objectif c'est de
trouver des paliers sur un parcours qui
est tenu secret jusqu'au jusqu'au jour j
l'équipage recherche encore des sponsors
pour pouvoir participer à l'épreuve elle
espère boucler leur budget avant la fin
mars